and you are one of the travelers chosen
you are regarding destiny two is out and
we know that for many of you this is
your first destiny the first decision
you face is what Guardian class you
should select don't be intimidated these
positions are modeled after familiar RPG
roles specifically the mage rogue and
tank tweaked to suit the fast and
fanatic pace and unique progression path
of destiny to each class also has a
brutal superpower and its cooldown can
be shortened depending on your advanced
abilities and equipped dear this video
primer goes over the first two of the
three subclasses of each class so you'll
know how to best tune and specialize
your guardian during the first dozen
hours of play if this video helped clear
things up be sure to give us a like and
subscribe to our YouTube channel once
you're all situated with your class be
sure to swing back to GameSpot for all
your other destiny 2 guides and tips
needs let's get started
the Titan is to go to if you want to
feel like a Space Marine a powerhouse
that can turn the tide of battle on its
sheer strength in skilled hands it can
stand its ground in a firefight partly
due to its 2 class ability barriers it's
a vertical ability lift modifies
mobility would increase height control
and your initial momentum burst Titans
are versatile tanks and unlocking
multiple subclasses will allow you to
further emphasize offense or defense you
start off with a defense centric
Sentinel the new void element id' and
subclass that replaces the previous
games defender its passive abilities
reward melee actions with defensive
benefits shields and health restoration
to be exact if you're having that
Captain America itch one of the coat of
the aggressor passive abilities grants
you an extra shield throw complimenting
the Sentinel shield super ifs melee
prowess makes it primed and ready for
the frontline supported bites various
barriers if you feel your fire team
lacks defensive support to balance out
its offense this subclass is for you the
arc elemental Titan striker meanwhile
makes a return but not without some
notable modification
it's the fist of havoc super has been
polarized two fists of heaven
you can now pull off multiple minion
clear and ground pounds as well as a
shoulder charge if you want to tighten
that doubles down on the class's
offensive strengths pick the striker
just look at the two passive ability
sets you get to choose from code of the
juggernaut encourages melee combat
resulting in health and weapon bonuses
code of the Earthshaker gives you more
opportunities to ground pound and
shoulder charge with the side benefit of
Auto recharging your grenades if you're
used to playing the rogue try your hand
at the hunter
The Guardian known for its a Joe Lee
craftiness and stealth all classes
features some form of mobility but the
hunters take it up a notch
using exclusive dodge skills with
bonuses and weapon reloading or melee
energy it also upgrades its double jump
with a triple jump high jump and strafe
jump if you like feeding off your
situational awareness in large spaces
the hunter's prowess in ranged combat
and ability to get out of dicey
situations will suit your needs if you
like complementing this nimble class
with the melee expertise of a samurai
you'll be pleased with the hunters
starter subclass Ark Strider which
replaces the Blade Dancer from the first
game
[Music]
it's super the arc staff is an energy
staff you wield acrobatically against
your foes the two passive ability pass
capitalizes on the fleet-footed 'no sub
the subclass following the way of the
wind offers benefits in increased
sprinting shortened dodge cooldowns and
reduced damage with using the arc staff
wave the warrior is suited for the more
assertive type granting dodge recharges
and attack damage boosts as you amass
kills if you're looking for a hunter in
the style of a cowboy and favor the
classes range expertise then walk the
path of the hunter gunslinger it's super
isn't called the Golden Gun for nothing
this fiery pistol use a solar light to
obliterate targets
many of its passive abilities are tied
to the super the way of the Sharpshooter
enhances your Golden Gun if you're
proficient in position kills the wave
the outlaw offers slightly more variety
from increased reload speed to an
exploding knife Warlocks our destiny to
space mages compared to the other
classes the warlocks mobility leans
towards horizontal movement making it
tough to target it's team healing
benefits are only overshadowed by its
potent attack spells as the support
class of Destiny to this Guardian is
best in the hands of those who are
actively aware of where your fireteam is
at all times this is to take advantage
of the warlocks main class abilities
Healing rift which is a close proximity
healer and empowering rift which
increases damage the Warlock dawn blade
replaces the previous game sunsinger
and the starting subclass is best suited
for those who look to take full
advantage of the warlocks mobility it's
super daybreak strikes from the sky
turning solar light into lethal blades
the dog blades wings aren't just for
show by choosing the attunement of the
sky passive abilities you can recharge
energy with airborne kills wings son and
Icarus - lets you attack and dodge
midair while swift strike is a flaming
melee attack that briefly boosts your
movement and reload speed if you want to
get the most out of daybreak choose a
tune of the flame it has a set of
passives that enhance the super
especially if you're too bloodthirsty
type the Warlock void Walker makes a
return with the Nova bomb super in tow
this demands high accuracy to get the
most bang for your buck both passive
ability routes for the void Walker excel
in variety attune men of chaos passives
benefits your grenades and modifies your
Nova bomb as an enemy seeker take a two
men of hunger if you want to feel like a
vampire with its devour ability you can
regenerate your health with melee kills
you can follow that up with insatiable
we're more melee kills increases the
duration of devour while also recharging
your grenades low on health use feed the
void to transfer grenade energy into
health regeneration as you progress
through the planets of destiny to random
drop artifacts will grant you access to
the second and third subclasses of each
guardian type and if one specialty isn't
working out for you changing between
your unlocked subclasses is as easy as
going into the menu you can even do this
mid battle happy hunting hunter or
warlock or Titan
[Music]